en el problema anterior olvidé mencionar
que la respuesta es d porque cada uno de
los incisos nos permite responder la
pregunta bueno vamos al problema 80 en
el problema 80 nos dicen que a veces son
enteros tenemos que a veces son enteros
y lo que nos piden determinar es si a
menos ve más se le gana es mayor que es
mayor que a más bm se ve - bueno
reacomodando algebraica mente esto
podemos restar a de ambos lados entonces
preguntarse esto es lo mismo que
preguntarse si menos b más se le gana a
b - c
y ahora sumándose de ambos lados aquí se
cancela nos queda 12 sumando b de ambos
lados aquí se cancelan nos queda 2 b
entonces esto es lo mismo a preguntarse
que si 12 le gana a 2 b o bien
preguntarse que si 2 bueno cancelamos el
2 o preguntarse que si se le gana a b
sale entonces queremos saber si esto
sucede vamos a ver qué información nos
dan la información uno es que b b es
negativo negativo si sabemos esto no
tenemos mucha información para decidir
con respecto a esto verdad si b es
negativo se podría ser negativo también
pero más chiquito o se podría ser
positivo o negativo y más grande que b
no sabemos gran cosa acerca de ese
entonces por sí misma estando nos
permite responder el inciso 2 dice c es
positivo
positivo positivo y este por sí mismo
tampoco nos permite responder si se es
positivo pues quien sabe que sea verdad
que se sea positivo así solito no nos
dice nada debe aunque sean enteros y lo
que sea entonces ésta por sí misma no
nos permite responder pero si sabemos
las dos al mismo tiempo entonces sí
podemos concluir porque como se es
positivo se le gana 0 como ves negativo
0 le gana a b y por lo tanto se le gana
a b entonces necesitamos la información
de los dos enunciados y por lo tanto la
respuesta sería c vamos ahora al
problema 81 en el problema 81 nos dicen
que una cierta caricatura consiste de 17
mil 280 fotogramas
fotogramas y lo que queremos saber es
cuánto dura la caricatura cuánto dura
cuánto dura bueno pues para saber cuánto
duran
tenemos que saber a qué velocidad se
está reproduciendo a cuántos fotogramas
por segundo o fotogramas por minuto de
hecho nos preguntan cuánto dura en
minutos eso es importante a lo mejor en
minutos entonces sería bueno saber pues
a cuántos fotogramas por minuto va o por
segundo y hacemos la conversión pero
bueno vamos a ver qué información nos da
nos dice uno nos dice uno la caricatura
se reproduce a 24 fotogramas por segundo
muy bien eso es justo lo que necesitamos
24 fotogramas por segundo si sabemos que
se reproduce a 24 fotogramas por segundo
entonces en segundos tardará 17 1280
dividido entre 24 o sea aquí arriba son
fotogramas estos fotogramas por segundo
entonces las unidades nos queda segundos
y aquí pues pudiéramos encontrar el
número pero no nos interesa sólo nos
interesa saber que se puede pero ojo
luego hay que cambiar estos minutos
entonces aquí tendríamos que hacer algo
del estilo poner 60 segundos en cada
minuto si entonces esto de aquí en
unidades ya nos quedaría minutos y aquí
nos quedaría un cierto número que
podemos calcular pero ahorita no es
importante lo único que nos interesa es
que esta información es suficiente vale
bueno vamos al inciso 2 este se ve más
interesante dice que toma seis veces más
reproducir la caricatura que regresarla
ok entonces le voy a poner
y la duración la duración es 6 veces lo
que tardamos en regresarla ok
va muy bien y en conjunto o sea
reproducirla y regresarla tarda 14
minutos o sea de más r es igual a 14 14
minutos pues otra vez aquí tenemos un
sistema de dos ecuaciones en dos
variables que podemos resolver ahorita
no lo voy a resolver o bueno si lo
resuelvo sale o sea que tendríamos de
sería 60 60
cr7 r entonces esto puede cambiarse a 7
r es igual a 14 minutos de donde eres
igual a 2 minutos y como de 60 tenemos
que de es igual a 12 minutos 12 minutos
vale en el examen de james pues esto
sería una pérdida de tiempo pero bueno
ahorita vamos con un poco más de calma y
por lo tanto esta ayuda esta ayuda y
entonces cada una de ellas por separado
resuelven la pregunta
entonces la respuesta es ve ahora vamos
al problema 82 en el problema 82 nos
dice que tenemos una caja que tiene
únicamente fichas rojas rojas blancas
blancas y azules y azules rojas blancas
y azules y se va a elegir una ficha al
azar de esa caja y lo que nos preguntan
es la probabilidad
la probabilidad de que la ficha sea
blanca blanca o azul blanca o azul muy
bien entonces sería bueno saber la
proporción de fichas blancas y azules
combinadas en la caja verdad bueno vamos
a ver qué información nos dan en la
información 1 nos dicen que la
probabilidad de que la ficha sea azul
azul es igual a un quinto esto no ayuda
a verdad esto no ayuda porque únicamente
nos dice la proporción de fichas azules
pero queremos la proporción de fichas
azules o blancas
entonces esto por sí mismo no es
suficiente a lo mejor lo podemos
combinar con el inciso 2 aquí nos dice
que la probabilidad
de que la ficha sea roja es igual a un
tercio se parece un poco al inciso y
entonces a no aquí hay que tener cuidado
no es lo mismo que el inciso a de hecho
a quien si nos están dando información
suficiente otra vez nada más nos dan
información de de un color pero esa
información ahora sí es importante
porque como las fichas solo son rojas
blancas y azules entonces la
probabilidad de que sea blanca o azul es
igual a 1 - la probabilidad de que sea
roja sale entonces si tenemos la
información del inciso 2
tenemos que eso es igual a 1 menos un
tercio que es igual a 2 a dos tercios
entonces esta si sirve y por lo tanto la
respuesta es b vamos al problema 83 ese
problema 82 y estuvo truculento en 83
como que nos hicieron nos querían hacer
creer que que eran muy parecidas estas
opciones pero la segunda si era
realmente útil bueno vamos al problema
en el problema 83 nos dimos dibujan algo
así como una recta numérica que se sigue
para allá y se sigue para allá y nos
marcan ciertas cosas por aquí está el
cero luego uno dos tres y aquí marcan
que está x luego otros tres uno dos tres
y acá al cuarto marcan que ésta y luego
marcan otro y se sigue se sigue para
allá y se sigue para allá ok entonces el
problema dice las marcas que se muestran
en la recta numérica de aquí arriba
están separadas de manera igual y xy son
números que están en los puntos que se
marcan cuál es el valor de james
ok entonces lo único que sabemos es que
estas estas distancias son todas iguales
pero no sabemos si son 1 o 5 o 10 pero
aunque no lo sepamos si hay cosas que
podemos saber por ejemplo si cada una de
estas me desde entonces tenemos que x x
es igual a 123 d
y sabemos que es 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 de 7 de
que es igual a 7 a 7 b y pues también
tenemos que x / g / es igual a 3 de
entre 7 de que es igual a 3 séptimos no
sé si eso vaya a ayudar pero es bueno
tener varias ecuaciones auxiliares vale
lo que queremos es determinar el valor
de y entonces conocer devasta o conocer
xv hasta verdad
conociendo x podemos despejar en esta de
acá bueno vamos a ver qué información
tenemos del inciso 1 nos dicen que x es
igual a un medio x es igual a un medio a
pues éste está súper buena verdad si x
es igual a un medio podemos sustituir
aquí entonces nos quedaría x como un
medio
voy a multiplicar cruzado 7x o sea 7
medios es igual a 3
multiplique 7 por xx es un medio me
queda siete medios multiplique tres
porque me queda tres entonces si es
igual a dividimos entre tres y es igual
a siete sextos vale bueno entonces está
de acá está buena y en el 2 nos dice que
nos dice que yemen os x
es igual a dos tercios es igual a dos
dos tercios la pues está combinada con
la segunda también nos va a permitir
determinar el valor de y de aquí tenemos
que x es igual a tres séptimos tres
séptimos de y vale entonces menos tres
séptimos de y eso cuánto es es cuatro
séptimos de verdad cuatro séptimos de y
es igual a dos tercios
el 7 lo pasamos multiplicando el 4 lo
pasamos dividiendo entonces nos quedaría
que es igual a 14 entre 12 y
simplificando la fracción dividiendo el
numerador y el denominador entre 2 nos
queda que ya es igual a 7 sextos
entonces esta de aquí también sirve así
solita solita no pero si nos dan como
hipótesis es dibujo y entonces
combinando la hipótesis con el inciso 2
podemos responder la pregunta vale
entonces la respuesta sería de cada una
de ellas por separado nos permite
responder la pregunta